very slight el famoso is expecting me
this is your office
the board is very impressed by oracle I
decided to widen your responsibilities
your private secretary your young that
you had all the right qualities has eyes
I'm Frau Hoffmeister so Ramiz at last
you're my husband's assistant and I'm
his wife
let's agree to be frank with each other
agreed or was Fallon strangely another
thing when she plays the spittin it
touch of it yes he's offered to give OTO
extra lessons soon have the whole family
under your wing it would be better if
you left your present lodgings and moved
in here three free I saw you
it's ridiculous this great table
separating us
we can't keep doing this doing what
lying to each other what on earth are
you imaginated Mexican leadership wants
to attract investment from Europe the
daughters why do
and y'all amount of the truth what I'm
to go to Mexico for two years two kids
never aged you can't I come with me
why didn't you tell me
I'll make a vow to each other
I promise to love each other only the
passion that touches it's a vest can
light the tinder of your utmost truth
only to hand who loses his home self
when self be given